avete mai pensato come i vostri gesti
quotidiani possano essere opportunità
per un grande cambiamento
vi do una buona notizia oggi tutti voi
siete protagonisti
i protagonisti di un opportunità di
crescita sociale
in che modo provate a pensare alla
realtà quotidiana a voi più vicina agli
oggetti alle azioni che compite tutti i
giorni vi alzate vi preparate
mettete le vostre cose in una borsa è
uscita per andare al lavoro
ora pensate una realtà quotidiana a voi
molto lontana
il carcere appunto se vi chiedo di
pensare al carcere cosa vi viene in
mente
mura cancelli rumori chiavi dolore
rabbia persone già perché in carcere si
stanno persone quindi come stanno in
relazione le nostre azioni quotidiane
gli oggetti che usiamo tutti i giorni e
le persone in carcere
la relazione nasce dal fatto che in
carcere alcune persone attraverso il
lavoro producono oggetti per il nostro
uso quotidiano e di questo io mi occupo
lavoro in carcere da 15 anni non sono
agente di polizia penitenziaria non sono
un funzionario pubblico ma sono la
presidente di una cooperativa sociale e
ho scelto di lavorare in carcere
l'ho scelto perché volevo contribuire a
rendere effettivo il principio di
rieducazione della pena che già
prescritto dalla nostra costituzione
l'ho scelto perché credo che il carcere
non possa e non debba essere solo un
luogo di esclusione di reclusione di
punizione gamma lavorare in carcere è
difficile noi con la cooperativa il
lavoro ce lo siamo dovuti inventare
era il 1995 a venezia ci sono due
carceri al carcere femminile alla
giudecca
abbiamo iniziato a inventarci il lavoro
a partire dal contesto un ex convento
con un bellissimo giardino abbandonato
ci sono voluti molti anni lavoro fatica
ma quel giardino oggi è un orto
biologico certificato di cui le donne
detenute si prendono cura e coltivano
ortaggi erbe officinali vicino all'orto
c'era un edificio anche quello
abbandonato e li abbiamo allestito un
moderno laboratorio di cosmetica per
trasformare
le erbe officinali in prodotti di
bellezza
il lavoro è lo strumento che noi
mettiamo a disposizione delle persone in
carcere degli uomini e delle donne che
vogliono cambiare attraverso il lavoro
si dà un'opportunità di rimettersi in
gioco di vedere la propria vita in
un'altra prospettiva di sperimentare
relazioni diverse di scoprire interessi
nuovi di avere anche un reddito ma un
reddito pulito di cui andare fieri e
attraverso questo reddito una nuova
dignità
ecco allora che una borsa fatta in
carcere da semplice oggetto contenitore
diventa un simbolo un simbolo di
cambiamento e un messaggero di storie
ecco che un cosmetico è simbolo di cura
della cura interiore prima ancora che di
quella esteriore
io chiamo questi oggetti ambasciatori
perché sono ambasciatori del lavoro ma
ancora di più sono ambasciatori di quel
percorso di crescita e di cambiamento
che le persone che riproducono stanno
attraversando nel senso comune si tende
a pensare che il carcere sia qualcosa
che non ci riguarda è altro da noi con
la cooperativa abbiamo voluto invece
aprire un canale di comunicazione tra
l'interno e l'esterno tra il mondo
recluso il mondo libero e per farlo
le collaborazioni con la nostra città
sono sempre state fondamentali
tantissime sono le persone che hanno
collaborato i detenuti le detenute
volontari professionisti collaboratori
che hanno messo a disposizione il loro
sapere hanno donato le loro idee per far
crescere il nostro progetto e rinnovarlo
nel tempo sono ormai più di vent'anni
vi racconto adesso l'ultima particolare
collaborazione che abbiamo avuto l'anno
scorso
abbiamo incontrato mark bradford mark
bradford è un artista un artista
contemporaneo tra i più importanti al
mondo era a venezia per rappresentare
gli stati uniti alla biennale
internazionale d arte ma lui voleva
avere un impatto sulla città che andasse
oltre il circuito chiuso del mondo
dell'arte e così ha cercato cercato nel
tessuto della nostra città e ha
incontrato il nostro progetto mi è
piaciuto così tanto che ha voluto
collaborare e ha voluto esserne parte
lui stesso abbiamo avviato una
collaborazione che si chiama prof.sse
collettivo pros il collettivo parte dal
principio di ascolto ascolto dei bisogni
delle persone in carcere bisogno di
lavoro
certo ma anche bisogno di essere visti
bisogno di essere presi in
considerazione e sul principio di
ascolto costruire un'offerta offerta di
opportunità ma i principi vanno poi resi
concreti e dalla concretezza siamo
partiti abbiamo aperto assieme un punto
vendita di prodotti fatti in carcere in
centro storico a venezia un luogo dove i
detenuti non sono più solo i produttori
nascosti sono essi stessi i
rappresentanti i testimoni del loro
lavoro e trovano in quella sede anche
opportunità di incontro e di scambio con
il mondo libero ecco dunque la buona
notizia
adesso è nelle vostre mani essere agenti
di cambiamento può essere semplice come
diventare consumatori consapevoli e
scegliere dei circuiti virtuosi essere
agenti di cambiamento può voler dire
volgere lo sguardo laddove nessuno
guarda e portare le proprie idee portare
le proprie passioni portare il proprio
lavoro
io spero che l'arte la musica il lavoro
e le passioni di ognuno possano
alimentare i tanti progetti che come il
nostro in tutto
italia fanno vivere le persone in
carcere in modo diverso per farle uscire
diverse
pensate che per chi in carcere fa per
corsi di rieducazione
il tasso di recidiva si abbassa dal 70
per cento fino al 20 per cento su una
popolazione detenuta di più di 50.000
persone vuol dire decine e decine
centinaia di persone che uscite dal
carcere non torneranno a delinquere
pensateci grazie
[Applauso]